nous sommes dans le green island le
restaurant de mon frère que je
représente pour le challenge des
créateurs on est ouverte depuis janvier
au début je travaillais en tant
qu'employé et depuis quelques mois je
suis passé co gérante
le bénin est un restaurant qui propose à
sa clientèle divers types de
restauration
la sandwicherie traditionnels les
burgers les kebabs les
les gratiné américain on a aussi le
produit phare de l'entreprise à battre
les compositions qui va nous permettre
de sortir un peu du lot et des
concurrents le client peut composer son
sandwich salade en fonction des aliments
qu'on propose le système de composition
attire les gens car c'est un peu c'est
amusant en fait de pouvoir concevoir son
sens du soi même et que la confection se
fait sous les yeux des clients donc ça
très amusant et divertissant
mon frère à la suite de ses études comme
ils ne trouvaient pas vraiment
travail donc il a été inscrit en tant
que demandeur d'emploi est l idée lui
est venue donc d'ouvrir son restaurant
étant donné qu'il avait déjà mis un pied
dans la restauration la structure
principale qui nous accompagnent a été
la boutique de gestion il a pu avoir
aussi un prêt nacre taux zéro tant
l'aide de ces structures je pense que il
aurait pris beaucoup plus de temps à
créer son entreprise ou voire même
peut-être baissé les bras et passer à
autre chose
depuis l'ouverture on a créer 15 emplois
aujourd'hui on se retrouve à trois
employés deux gérants avec les employés
ça se passe super bien j'ai pas besoin
d'être derrière tout le temps ils savent
ce qu'il faut faire ils sont dévoués à
leur travail tous les mois on reçoit un
nouveau stagiaire
donc ça permet aux jeunes de collège ou
de lycée de découvrir le monde de
l'entreprise
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est une
entreprise familiale dont qu'on a on à
ma femme principalement qui vient qui
nous donne des petits coups de main
quand on a besoin dans cette chance là
justement d'avoir le soutien de la
famille aurait sable a décidé d'ouvrir
le green island
ça m'a semblé une idée un peu farfelue
j'avoue que j'étais très sceptique et
deux frères qui travaillent ensemble d
j'ai émis des doutes mais ça a très vite
fonctionné en fait c'est une équipe qui
fonctionne très bien et extrêmement
fiers d'eux de mon beau-frère surtout il
a commencé de rien il était simple
employé dans un kebab en métropole
effectivement et il a dit découvrir
toutes les tâches toutes les facettes de
l'entrepreneuriat et de sel c'est que ça
peut être compliqué donc moi je suis
très très fier d'eux l'idée de
participer au challenge des créateurs
ça a été avant tout une vitrine
médiatique avec cette aide financière
l'idée ça serait donc d'investir dans du
nouveau matériel et dans la formation
pour les employés